micro [ __ ] content written know your
audiences you got your prospectus
[Music]
25 minutes TV shows killing it good
thing on the entrepreneur OTT yeah
what did you what's the 200,000 let me
see it real quick I mean it's super fun
for me to look at this because it's so
like the model yeah like it feels so
first and foremost you're not putting up
enough content like like there's silver
that we don't put out yeah no it's I
don't like first and foremost this is
one day ago the next piece is four days
ago in three days without posting like
I'm posting board now actually I'm a
little down and I'm upset about and
we're like truck like we're like I've
like eight step for the last 45 days
I've gone away from my four times a day
five times a day to two or three a day
you're posting once every three days in
that example I think you aren't posting
enough let me tell you something that's
super important that we've come to
realize the micro contents more
important in the macro content
you're producing are you producing a
blog right don't put the vlog on the
pedestal put the pieces of content from
the daily vlog on the pedestal it's a
reverse right 100% the five or six magic
moments or you know right now we're like
in this really realizing it's sage so
we're having a lot of fun because we
keep looking at each other because every
time we have a moment which used to be a
good scene from the blog we know is
going to be a separate video I mean I
had a I had a video for me and yg the
rapper that got 1.4 million views on on
Instagram that like the blog got 29
thousand views for the whole episode so
so if you want I G I mean a couple
things couple things to talk about first
I think everyone's getting sucked into
IG period meaning it's so cool it showed
the platform but like look not
everybody's gonna over index on IG like
IG is you know for example I would like
to see you put out four pieces of
content a day on LinkedIn you will
impact their business way more if you do
that
for what I'm seeing first and foremost
it's a volume game number two I think
you um I think you are mailing in the
copy too much so I think one of the
myths in the market right now is people
are mailing in copy because it's also
visual you'd be blown away how much I
believe real good cop any like beat you
heart
I like that actually cuz sometimes it's
good to just be like but you're kind of
doing that in the content this is where
you can really pontificate like I think
one of the reasons why I Chi does so
well is I you know maybe people can tell
cuz I have no grammar skills like I
write my copy and as you can see like I
kind of go I my best I go there I go
there I like write [ __ ] I think it
matters what's that
would make sense content more content
it's not enough volume first is like you
know you're like how do I shoot more
deer it'd be nice if you shot 88 times a
day not for let's start there
comma okay now you're talking about
strategy should I go on a [ __ ] tree
you know volume volume volume
collaboration collaboration
collaboration the way to grow an IG is
get to other people to co-sign you make
content that brings people value other
people you've got access right I would
have a strategy on the team of like
athletes or business people that have
big followings figure out how to get in
front of them I know it is but but I
would argue that I'm not so sold that IG
is the best cuz the reality is like not
and I mean this like there's a level of
like puncher in IG that is going to feel
forced if you go too hard at it
I got lucky like I don't know what else
to say I got lucky that I grew up in
Edison New Jersey that I went to an all
black college like I I got lucky that
there was some hidden cool in me that
feels authentic now that this is here
I'll be really honest if I was your
business fire me like [ __ ] that podcast
IG choose me podcasting LinkedIn podcast
LinkedIn the other question is what do
you want to happen I actually want
global awareness and admiration and fame
admiration so IG super important to me
you know I want to sign athlete like
it's really good that all these 5-star
recruits all follow me now
that by the time we get our bait you
know when I was talking about patience
because I know right now I have every 18
year old that's a five-star recruit
who's going to come out in 24 36 months
and we'll be ready for that
you know so but what the [ __ ] are you
doing right so like if you're and like
you know there's your noble goal and
then there's your financial goal and
everything has to map to that right I'm
by the way a lot of my friends and I
actually believe in this a lot if your
financial goal enables you to use your
noble goal to be just writing checks to
charity then go over I'm thrilled being
a businessman I don't bring awareness to
my nonprofit I do that quietly um I
think the best thing I can do the world
is [ __ ] rewire everybody's head
that's what I'm doing well I'm I'm like
I'm attacking depression and like I'm
doing real [ __ ] without it being so
obvious it's getting more obvious
unfortunately which which I'm not
kidding makes it harder to do anyway
volume is number one to many of you
without knowing or in the bigger piece
of content business not in the micro
business d-roc used to want to make
movies win Academy Awards now he's more
excited about making one Instagram
chopped up video I could see I know him
I know him if he makes a video that gets
17 million views on Instagram in the
next four months he's going to be on a
high for a month about it
because the most we've ever done there -
I think right so written word written
word yeah man you got you're gonna have
to go through your own process of
creative ego - practicality of the world
we now live in you you're gonna be by
the way you're gonna be forced into
figuring it out cuz it's gonna be buggin
[Music]
yeah that's the part you were forced
into it but now you've learned to love
it what race is still like the longest
and they like artsy I think you should
be in the milk copy transcribing that
interview with you bye bye don't go live
no yes yes yes yes yes that's the one
and I get it and it's still honestly
that's the number one question people
should be asking for the number one
question people should be asking me is
what is why and what is working for me
because that's that's it film everything
and make 81 pieces of content from it in
a day and don't do a [ __ ] blog I
would literally not do a blog over the
article on LinkedIn I mean goli answer
questions on Quora with your content
yeah there's so much you've been doing
ok
you should put this video up as much as
I should because then you could leverage
me you couldn't run it against garyvee
fans on Facebook yes but you don't
either protect us
you mean the fans themselves they're
protective because if you try to do it
just to get them to be on you they'll
[ __ ] kill you because I made them so
authentic but if you actually try to
bring value and if you go in humility
and be like just like all of you I love
you you're always very you're very smart
so it's gonna be easy for you be like I
also view Gary as a mentor that comes
with humility they'll [ __ ] love you
if you're like trying to come in there
like a lot of other people and try to
take their money cuz I'm giving free
[ __ ] but you know what I mean that's
why
[Music]